let's say we have two lines over here
let's call this line right over here
line a b
so a and b both sit on this line and
let's say we have this other line over
here and we'll call this line cd so it
goes through point c and it goes through
point d and it just keeps on going
forever
and let's say that these lines both sit
on the same plane and in this case the
plane is our screen or this little piece
of paper that we're looking at right
over here and they never intersect
they never intersect so they're on the
same plane but they never intersect each
other they never intersect if those two
things are true then and they're not the
same line they never intersect and they
can be on the same plane then we say
that these lines are parallel
we say that they are parallel they're
moving in the same general direction
in fact the exact same general direction
if we were looking at it from an
algebraic point of view we would say
that they have the same slope but they
have different y-intercepts they involve
different points if we drew our
coordinate axes here they would
intersect that at a different point but
they would have the same exact slope and
what i want to do is think about how
angles relate to parallel lines so right
over here we have these two parallel
lines we can say that a b
line a b
is parallel is parallel to line cd
is parallel to line cd sometimes you'll
see it specified on g on geometric
drawings like this they'll put a little
arrow here to show that these two lines
are parallel and if you've already used
the single arrow they might put a double
arrow to show that this line is parallel
to that line right over there
now with that out of the way what i want
to do is draw a line that intersects
both of these parallel lines
so here's a line that intersects both of
them let me draw a little bit neater
than that so let me draw that line right
over there and i'll just call that i'll
just call that line well actually i'll
do some points over here well i'll just
call that line l and this line that
intersects both of these parallel lines
we call that a transversal
this is a transversal line it is
transversing both of these parallel
lines this is a transversal
and what i want to think about is the
angles that are formed and how they
relate to each other the angles that are
formed at the intersection between this
transversal line and the two parallel
lines so we could first of all start off
with this angle right over here
that angle right over there and we could
call that angle well if we made if we
made some labels here that would be d
this point and then something else but
i'll just call it this angle right over
here we know that that's going to be
equal to its vertical angles so that
this angle is vertical with that one so
it's going to be equal to that angle
right over there
we also know that this angle right over
here is going to be equal to the angle
that is that its vertical angle or the
or the angle that is opposite the
intersection so it's going to be equal
to that and sometimes you'll see it
specified like this
we'll see a double angle mark like that
or sometimes you'll see someone write
this to show that these two are equal
and these two are equal right over here
now the other thing we know is we can do
the exact same exercise up here that
these two are going to be equal to each
other and these two are going to be
equal to each other they're all vertical
angles what's interesting here is
thinking about the relationship is
thinking about the relationship between
this angle right over here
the relationship between that angle
right over there and this angle
right up over here
and if you just look at it it is
actually obvious what that relationship
is that they are going to be the same
exact angle that if you put a protractor
here and measured it you would get the
exact same measure up here and if i drew
parallel lines maybe i'll draw it
straight left and right and it might be
a little bit more obvious that if i draw
so if i assume that these two lines are
parallel and i have a transversal here
what i'm saying is that this angle is
going to be the exact same measure as
that angle there and to visualize that
just imagine tilting this line and as
you take different so it looks like it's
the case over there if you take the line
like this and you look at it over here
it's clear that this is equal to this
and there's actually no proof for this
this is one of those things that are
that a mathematician would say is
intuitively obvious that if you look at
it as you tilt this line you would say
that they're going that these angles are
the same or think about putting a
protractor here to actually measure
these angles if you put a protractor
here
this you'd have one side of the angle at
the zero degree and the other side would
would specify that point and if you put
the protractor over here
if you put the protractor over here the
exact same thing would happen one side
would be on this parallel
line and the other side would point at
the exact same point so given that we
know that not only not only is this side
equivalent to this side it is also
equivalent to this side over here and
that tells us that that's also
equivalent to that side over there so
all of these things in green are
equivalent and by the same exact
argument this side right over here is
going or this angle is going to have the
same measure as this angle and that's
going to be the same as this angle
because they are opposite now or they're
vertical angles now the important thing
to to realize is just what we've deduced
here the vertical angles are equal and
the corresponding angles at the same
points of intersection are also equal
and so that's a new word that i'm
introducing right over here this angle
and this angle are corresponding they
represent kind of the top right corner
in this example of where we intersected
here they represent the i still i guess
the top or the top right corner of the
intersection this would be the top left
corner top left corner they're always
going to be equal corresponding angles
and once again it comes really just it's
a i guess for lack of a better word it
is a bit obvious
now on top of that there are other words
that people will see we've essentially
just proven that not only is this angle
equivalent to this angle but it's also
equivalent to this angle right over here
and these two angles maybe if i call
this let me label them so that we can we
can make some headway here so i'm going
to use lowercase letters for the angles
themselves so let's call this lowercase
a lowercase b
lowercase c so lowercase c for the angle
lowercase d and then let me call this e
f
g h so we know from vertical angles that
b is equal to c but we also know that b
is equal to f because they are
corresponding angles it's equal to f and
that f is equal to g
so vertical angles are equivalent
corresponding angles are equivalent and
so we also know obviously that b is
equal to g and so we say that alternate
interior angles are equivalent so you
see that they're kind of on the interior
of the intersection they're between the
two lines but they're on all opposite
sides of the transversal now you don't
have to know that that fancy word
alternate interior angles you really
just have to deduce this what we just
saw over here know that vertical angles
are going to be equal and corresponding
angles are going to be equal and you see
it with the other ones too we know that
a is going to be equal to d which is
going to be equal to h which is going to
be equal which is going to be equal to
e